MESSAGES WASN'T REFLECTED IN
THEIR COVERAGE THAT DAY.
JOHN AVLON HAS MORE IN TODAY'S
REALITY CHECK.
>> WHEN THE CAPITOL WAS
ATTACKED, THEY KNEW IT HAD ALL
GONE TOO FAR.
FOX NEWS HOSTS WERE TEXTING WITH
WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF STAFF
BEGGING HIM TO HAVE TRUMP CALL
THE RIOTERS OFF.
RARELY DOES HISTORY ALLOW YOU TO
SEE WHAT PEOPLE WERE THINKING IN
REAL TIME.
BUT THESE TEXTS DO.
AND ONE IS ESPECIALLY REVEALING.
THIS IS HURTING ALL OF US.
THAT'S WHAT LAURA INGRAM SAID.
AND THE ALL OF US THERE DOESN'T
SEEM TO MEAN ALL AMERICANS.
IT MEANS THE RIGHT WING WATER
CARRIERS FOR TRUMP.
THESE TEXT MESSAGES RIPPED THE
CURTAIN BACK, IT SHOWS THEY
THOUGHT OF THEMSELVES AS
PARTISAN POLITICAL ENABLERS
FIRST, NOT JOURNALISTS, AND THEY
KNEW IT WASN'T A MOSTLY PEACEFUL
PROTEST.
THAT SHOCK OF RECOGNITION ONLY
LASTED A FEW MINUTES BECAUSE
HOURS LATER THEY WERE BACK IN
HYPERPARTISAN DISTORTION LAND,
SPREADING DESPERATE DEFLECTIONS
AND FOX NEWS VIEWERS WERE ONCE
AGAIN BEING PLAYED FOR FOOLS.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> I HAVE NEVER SEEN TRUMP RALLY
ATTENDEES WEARING HELMETS, BLACK
HELMETS, BROWN HELMETS, BLACK
BACKPACKS, THE UNIFORMS THAT YOU
SAW IN SOME OF THESE CROWD
SHOTS, HAVE YOU EVER SEEN THEM
WEARING AS CHRIS SAID THOSE KNEE
PADS AND THE -- ALL THE PADS ON
THEIR ELBOWS?
I JUST -- I'VE BEEN TO A LOT OF
THE RALLIES, I KNOW YOU BOTH
HAVE COVERED THEM, I'VE NEVER
SEEN THAT BEFORE.
EVER.
>> EVERYONE KNEW GOING IN TODAY
THIS CROWD WAS GOING TO BE
MASSIVE.
THEY KNEW THERE WERE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE THAT CAME TO
TOWN.
WE ALSO KNEW THERE IS ALWAYS BAD
ACTORS THAT WILL INFILTRATE
LARGE CROWDS.
I DON'T CARE IF THE RADICAL
LEFT, RADICAL RIGHT, I DON'T
CARE WHO THEY ARE, THEY'RE NOT
PEOPLE I WOULD SUPPORT.
HOW WERE OFFICIALS NOT PREPARED?
WE GOT TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION.
>> THEY KNEW THIS WASN'T SOME
FALSE FLAG OPERATION.
THEY KNEW IT WASN'T ANTIFA OR
BLACK LIVES MATTER BECAUSE THEY
KNEW IN REAL TIME THAT THE
CAPITOL WAS BEING ATTACKED BY
TRUMP SUPPORTERS.
BUT THEIR INABILITY TO TELL THE
TRUTH WHEN THE MICROPHONES WERE
ON ALLOWED THE BIG LIE TO
METASTASIZE.
IT IS NOT SURPRISING THAT LAST
NIGHT AS LIZ CHENEY WAS READING
THE NEW EVIDENCE OUT LOUD, FOX
WAS IGNORING THE WHOLE THING,
OFFERING UP THIS IRONIC INSTANT
CLASSIC OF A BANNER AT THE
BOTTOM OF THE SCREEN, TALKING
ABOUT LAWLESSNESS.
BECAUSE, OF COURSE, WHAT IS
BEING REVEALED IS JUST HOW
LAWLESS THE TRUMP REPUBLICAN
PARTY REALLY IS.
BEYOND THE TEXTS OVER THE LAST
FEW DAYS WE LEARNED EVEN MORE
ABOUT HOW THIS ATTEMPT TO
DISRUPT AND OVERTURN THE
ELECTION WAS BEING QUARTERBACKED
OUT OF THE WHITE HOUSE.
THE 9,000 PAGES OF DOCUMENTS
THAT MARK MEADOWS HANDED OVER TO
THE COMMITTEE BEFORE BELATEDLY
CLAIMING EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE, WE
CAN SEE IN THEIR OWN WORDS HOW
CLOSE AMERICA CAME TO HAVING
DEMOCRACY DISMANTLED.
LESS THAN A WEEK AFTER THE
ELECTION, THERE IS AN EMAIL
SHOWING EFFORTS TO PRESSURE
STATE LEGISLATORS TO APPOINT
PRO-TRUMP ELECTORS OVER THE
BIDEN ELECTORS CHOSEN BY THE
VOTERS.
WE HAVE GOTTEN SOME INSIGHT INTO
MEADOWS EFFORTS TO PRESS FEDERAL
AGENCIES TO INVESTIGATE INSANE
ELECTION CONSPIRACY THEORIES
INVOLVING FOREIGN NATIONS FROM
ITALY TO CHINA AND CLAIMS OF
REMOTE HACKING WITH SATELLITES
AND EVEN THERMOSTATS.
WE HAVE SEEN OTHER MEMOS FROM
TRUMP LAWYERS, AND REPORTS ABOUT
AN UNHINGED POWER POINT FULL OF
CONSPIRACY THEORIES WHOSE AUTHOR
SAYS HE MET WITH MEADOWS IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
NOT ONLY THAT, THE CHIEF OF
STAFF WAS COMMUNICATING WITH
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS, TRYING TO
OVERTURN THE ELECTION WHILE ALSO
ASSURING AT LEAST ONE PERSON
THAT THE NATIONAL GUARD WOULD
PROTECT PRO TRUMP PEOPLE ON
JANUARY 6th.
THIS IS THE OPPOSITE OF LAW AND
ORDER.
IT IS THE MOST SICKENING EXAMPLE
OF PUTTING PARTISANSHIP OVER
PATRIOTISM IN OUR HISTORY.
THEY WERE ACTIVELY TRYING TO
OVERTURN DEMOCRACY JUST TO STAY
IN POWER, AND THE FACT THAT SO
MANY OF THEM WERE WILLINGLY
DUPED BY THE BIG LIE SPEAKS TO
HOW PERVASIVE IT HAD BECOME ON
RIGHT WING TALK TV.
IN THOSE DESPERATE TEXTS, MAYBE
FOX HOSTS REALIZE THEY HELPED
CREATE THE CONDITIONS THAT LED
TO THE CAPITOL ATTACK.
AND NOW, THEY'RE RESPONSIBLE FOR
PERPETUATING THE BIG LIE, WHICH
ALLOWED THE LEADER OF AN
ATTEMPTED COUP TO AIM FOR THE
PRESIDENCY AGAIN.
IT IS ALL EVIDENCE OF